you
[Music]
today pleased to have Dave Dave LeMay
accepted to do this talk on cost
performance he gave a really interesting
talk at the Dayman workshop it at sigmod
and was under a lot of time pressure
therefore obviously for shorter
presentations so he'll have a little
more time today to to really spell out
the details so this is this is my effort
to give an entertaining talk as well as
an informative one we'll have to see how
that goes so this is pretty much the
same slides that I used at de Mon so so
what's happening in traditional
databases and and what's this what's the
situation that were that we're facing so
this is the slide that I unscrupulously
borrow the idea for from from Mike
Stonebreaker where where he showed that
the traditional database systems are
being squeezed by the special-purpose
data stores and and so so this is the
way the picture looks it got streaming
on one corner column store and the other
and main memory row stores at the top
and the situation is perceived to be
getting even even worse and these these
separate areas are growing and and the
comment that Stonebraker made was
instead of we instead of having a one
size fits all we have a one size fits
none where where the traditional vendors
are really being squeezed and their
markets are being taken away and and so
this is a pretty pretty challenging
situation and you know so the question
is are they are the crystal yes so
previous slide and in distributing were
Stonebraker stated or are you repeating
are you stating it as a fact that our
memory systems and the schema systems
are mainly grown as big as to include a
few sparse
and so this so yeah memory systems of
these traditional vendors maybe maybe
are dead and what about Amazon Aurora
well you know they may be next right not
this is not what's happening in fact the
elephants are continuing to dance
there's been no sign that that the that
the screaming folks or the columnstore
folks or the main memory database folks
are really taking significant market
share from the traditional vendors and
so the question is why right and and so
here's what's happening right you got
the traditional vendors with screaming
they've sort of formed a partnership
where screaming and and and the
traditional database vendors live side
by side happily in peace walking off
into the sunset
the columnstore stop has been pretty
much absorbed into into the main
traditional database engines and the
main memory rose stores well they're
sort of a niche market right and and so
so the question is and what I'm gonna
focus mostly on is is the main memory
rose store part and the niche market
part and the question to be asked is why
why is that happening
why has why has that turned out to be
the result
and so there's economic factors in play
and so we're working on cloud
infrastructure the cloud infrastructure
has to be cheap commodity the software
infrastructure has to run on that
effective way on that on that sort of
commodity hardware this is a world where
there's elastic provisioning that is to
say you wouldn't when somebody doesn't
use the resources you want to free them
up so that someone else can use them
instead you want basically the the
resources that go to the person who's
got the most money and willing to pay
for them right and so you want to give
up resources to higher valued
applications so the fact is that money
talks and doesn't matter whether it's
what kind of money it is money talks
matters matters a lot and so and so what
we'll see is that money is talking very
clearly I think in this case and
and and so so let's proceed and see what
happens so so what's the story with
traditional database systems they're
they're what I call caching data stores
they're not main memory storage the
cache in data stores okay so traditional
database systems actually do offer good
cost performance oh the costs vary so we
need to we need to stop being fixated on
on solely on performance we need to
start thinking about cost as well as
performance traditional database systems
have have performance that is lower than
the main memory systems that's sort of a
fact of life and yet they succeed in
having better cost performance which is
sort of interesting why should that be
so what I'm going to do is suggest also
at the end a change in the focus of our
field to not surprisingly be more
focused on cost performance than pure
performance so caching what is the cache
in datastore well it uses a cache of
course it does right and and what is a
casual well you move data from secondary
storage to main memory when the data
needs to be operated on and you move it
back out of main memory when you're
through using it or when it's no longer
makes any sense to keep it in cash
because it's no longer hot and and so so
it's this movement between main memory
and secondary storage which is the
significant factor and why the good
traditional traditional database systems
are in fact still succeeding very well
the fact is here the data lives
permanently on secondary storage and
it's only brought in to the main memory
as a caching proposition where this
where you act on it in main memory and
that's a very significant factor so I'm
going to talk about two forms of
operation this is a little bit of an
abstraction of abstract way of thinking
about it but here's here's what I'm
gonna go look at the main memory
operations going to call mmm there are
the operations which find the data in
main memory
and they're very fast if you find the
data in Maine remember you just have a
execution path through your access
method or whatever and get to shovel the
results back out to the users the second
set of operations is what I call
secondary storage operations secondary
storage operations are the ones where
you find the data on secondary storage
you find it on on usually that means
flash nowadays and and they're more
expensive to execute by abaya
not insignificant factor than the main
memory operations are the reason why
that is is because we dealing with data
that's saying sitting currently on
secondary storage you have to bring it
into memory memory first that's that's
an operation which which which costs
some some amount of both dollars and
time and then you have to do the main
memory operation after you bring after
you've written the operation into main
memory so so that's going to be going to
be more expensive both in terms of
performance impact and in terms of
dollars so looking at it this way
cashing stores look like a bad idea and
here's a chart which shows why it's a
bad idea
what it shows is that if you as you mix
secondary storage operations into the
mix with with with main memory
operations guess what the performance
declines what I've done here with these
these lines is simply show that that
this is a weighted average of the
operations and we did some experiments
actually James did them which produce
the the results in the in the dots in
between and I summarized the results as
the ratio between secondary storage
operations and main memory operations is
around five point eight so so that says
that you know if you if you have memory
on secondary storage you can expect that
you want your performance will not be as
good as it will be remember today's
always in main memory so this is what is
proposed
the issue that has set trooper yeah
exactly
it's relative trooper yes that's right
so this looks like it might be a
performance disaster let's say each each
an additional secondary stock secondary
storage operation pushes the performance
of our and and it pushes it actually for
whatever the main remember whatever the
secondary storage operations are so so
when you're when you're at the let me go
back a minute when you're at at this end
of the graph you're getting main memory
performance at least for the caching
system main memory and at the far end
you're getting something close to
secondary storage operations so so why
bother why bother with with caching
systems because costs matter so so now I
want to take a look at this a little
harder to talk let's look at cost
performance not just performance but
cost performance there are two costs for
operating on data there are storage
costs storage costs are paid all the
time data has to sit someplace the
storage costs are most of the cost for
cold data so what what is that why is
that well you're not operating on it so
there's no execution cost so storage
cost is a factor whenever you have a big
factor whenever you have relatively cold
data the other cost is execution cost
this this cost is pay when you're
actually executing on the data and it's
most of the cost of hot data or when
data becomes hot so so you know if
you're really banging on data very very
hard are you going to be paying the
execution cost and this is where the
main memory systems have their advantage
but if you're if you're if you're
looking to service cold data as well
the cold data is going to be sitting on
secondary storage if you have a caching
system whereas if you have a main memory
system it's going to be sitting in a
memory and memory systems that you'll
see are more costly than secondary
storage
so it's about relative costs here so we
have storage costs and we have execution
costs so if you look at this is the
ratio these are the ratios between
between main memory costs and flash
storage there are there aren't any
numbers here there are numbers in my
daemon paper but there aren't any
numbers here there's just just showing
relative relative costs so main memory
is approximately a factor of 10 more
expensive than than flash memory on the
other side when you're talking about
execution costs these are these are
these are numbers which I derived from
from the PW tree the main memory
operation is very low cost in me and the
flash executing stuff from flash memory
is very costly let me come over here and
talk to you about this so so Cheers
after you bring stuff in from from flash
you have to execute on it so that's this
cost here this is the cost of the i/o
path this is the cost of of the of the
of the processor executing the i/o
instruction going through going through
the i/o stack and this is the cost of
buying a secondary storage operation on
flash
so these operations on flash you have to
you have to pay for them too this is
analogous to what gray talked about when
he talked about fine disk operations in
his five-minute wallpaper yeah like for
example if you have five terabytes of
data right an in memory system Wi-Fi
provider memory system is going to be
not really more expensive than 100
gigabyte in memory systems or gigabytes
right whereas you can easily have a five
terabyte nvme system which is more or
less commodities these days so I think
the price also probably starts
increasing as so if you want to go with
larger data volumes there so there's any
number of ways of making this more
complex okay so this is if there is not
this assuming this standard like maybe
hundred gigabytes of that kind of this
is a standard commodity about prices Oh
so so these are relative costs and I'll
have some more things to say about it
later and and the reason why so
previously it used to cost you a lot to
buy an i/o access but the current SS
deeds give you hundreds of thousands of
i/o I ops and and so the end result is
that that drives down the cost of about
buying a house substantially so this is
this is the cost of buying one i/o
operation executing yes so on the left
and right the cost of different units
although that is kind of yeah they're
not they're not the same that's right
I'm not these are just relative numbers
relative numbers here relative members
they're trying to say like on the left
side you are counting dollars how many
like money or pay first or I'm coming
I'm coming dollars on the right as well
well how much of the of the processor
you you consume when it doing your
execution okay how much of the SSDs I
ops capability your by so it's costs on
both sides okay so we compute cost
plotted against operations per second so
here I'm going to explain to you I'm
going to show you this is the math
that's probably the only math I'm still
capable of doing but but here's here's
the math involved so the cost will turn
out to be a linear function of the
storage and execution costs and here's
what it looks like so here's the here's
the here's the linear function so you
have costs per second what we're going
to calculate equals a which is the cost
for renting the storage for that in that
period of time plus B which is the cost
per operation times the number of
operations you're executing alright so
so so what's going to happen is that
what we're going to show is that you
know this is a cost which you always pay
and this is the cost what you pay based
on how many operations per second you're
executing
now this I hope this is clear because
I'm going to I'm gonna sort of depend
upon this analysis and the rest of the
talk so what is a storage storage course
it's it's its cost per byte times the
size of the data and and and again the
interesting thing here is that DRAM
costs ten times the cost of the flash at
when you're executing no operations
storage cost is the entire cost of
managing the data okay and you'll see
when I talk when I showed you the graph
in the next slide you'll see that that's
the y-intercept in the graph one over
here over on this end when zero
operations going on the execution cost
is whatever the cost per operation is
and that's what I showed you in the
previous slides that was the cost per
operation times the number of operations
per second we're executing so remember
that now what and what I should graph
that I showed before that the secondary
storage operation is a factor of 12 or
so more expensive than the main memory
operation because you have to you have
to buy the i/o path and you have to buy
the eye ops from from the from the SSD
so so this this cost if you go back here
this cost determines the slope of the
line so this is again a little linear
equation which would chef relates the
cost of the various pieces to the total
cost that you face and so here's here's
the graph over on this side where
there's there's zero operations the cost
is all the storage cost and here you can
see that the storage cost for for main
memory is a factor of ten more than the
cost of the secondary storage operation
now as you go to the to the to the right
this goes up by a factor of twelve
faster than this this secondary storage
operation goes up by a factor of 12
faster
then the main memory operation does okay
so not surprisingly at some point they
meet and that's what graze five-minute
rule showed except that the computation
suggested it's now around one minute
largely again because SSDs produce so
many more outs the interesting thing
about data caching systems is that they
have the opportunity to choose the lower
level lower lower cost operation now
nobody does this precisely but the
potential is that we all sort of try to
get good caching policies so that we
approximate this curve where we're
always using the lowest cost operation
to manage our data can't you get the red
line performance with caching locality
crimes if you have if you have extremely
high cache at rate then well then then
you're out bringing over here thing this
is the high hops per second area this is
the low ops per second area by
definition you have having low well-hit
ratio over on this side where you're
having - make sure it's okay so that's
why that's the additional degree of
freedom that caching systems have versus
versus the other kinds of system so so
what about the other kinds of systems
and now I'm gonna have there's two
comparisons are going to show you talk
about and one is main memory systems
okay so memory system their performance
is better and then in a caching system
and indeed their performance is better
than a fully cached caching system
there's a lot of paths that they they
don't have to execute they can use
specific and more tightly bound to main
memory the assumption that all the
memory all the data is in memory so they
may in fact have a better performance
and so here's the comparison so mastery
has higher performance than
do Durrani's b/w tree executed around
2.6 or so factor faster than the b/w
tree does it turns out it takes and this
is sort of interesting it takes in main
memory now it takes around 2.3 times the
amount of storage at the main that the
BW tree takes okay say well one thing to
remember so I'll have qualifiers on this
a little bit later so so what does that
mean so that means that you've got this
this cost graph here again remember siz
the our old secondary storage operation
with it with it rising very sharply this
is the the the Deuteronomy a a curve
where where main memory curve where
where it goes up slowly and this is the
this is the mastery way up here it's
notice its costs in terms of storage is
approximately twice the cost of the bbw
tree and it goes up very very slowly
right and where it crosses is that
around a hit ratio of once every three
seconds for a fork a page this this
ratio over here is about one one one
minute when you when you cross between a
secondary storage operation and the
Deuteronomy main memory operation so
your data has to be really hot in order
in order for you to profit from the
higher performance of may of mastery at
least in terms of its cost implications
so deuteronomy's cost performance is
better all the way over to the
three-second point and that's the region
where where where the mastery is better
if you've got super hot datum but unlike
the case where we're switching here
between main memory operations and
secondary storage operations there's no
switching between between between the BW
tree and masteries you're sort of
committed one way or the other you and
so you have to you have to be prepared
to to choose which system you're going
to use from this start and so I think I
did a little calculation
so if you're executing on a 40 gigabyte
database then you have to be executing
at least 3 million operations per second
before before you're you're better off
in terms of cost by using our using the
mastery all right so there's another
aspect and this is another system I
wanted to compare with although this is
much more hypothetical we did no
experiments on this Facebook Pro yeah so
how are you talking about diamonds those
are the those are the that speed
interval and what between operations for
a piece of data and it's using a fork
fork a page is only a matter of trying
to try to measure the general same what
the temperature is of the day on a page
again with with the BW tree versus math
screen you don't really have that choice
right and the mastery isn't patinated
anyway so it's so but but this gives you
an idea of what the relative
temperatures are above these of these
things okay so now what about what about
people who have enormous amounts of data
like Facebook ok Facebook had a really
bad problem because they wanted good
performance on cold data and they were
worried about costs so they were in such
a bad shape that they were actually but
this is this is a side your paper from a
couple of years ago sure should have
probably included a reference to it but
the the they were they were they were
buying more processors not because they
needed more processors they were buying
more processors so that it can't act
more SSDs right to accommodate the huge
volume of data and or more PCI
connections or the bottleneck for the
CPU time was know obsessed about
connectivity to
to the boxes welcome I mean like it
couldn't be solved by putting more cores
than CPU or do you need to have like
more motherboards with more PC a
connection you need to be able to attach
more SSDs I don't know what the answer
is beyond that okay
I think there's in the commodity space I
think you mean by box and you to be
limited to how many connections you can
make SSDs okay so in that case they was
doing walk plates like really low
powered CPUs but lock them off of them
yeah yeah that was a good position
everywhere okay okay so what was it what
was their solution well they were using
a data caching system and what to that
they added data compression as well okay
so so they needed low latency so to use
SSD storage but and they scaled out the
processes for a good performance and
then they use data compression to lower
their storage costs so what were they
doing in this in this this model of
performance that I've been showing you
know okay so I'm going to walk through
this this is our old number on secondary
storage operations this is the the
number for the deuteronomy's may be with
w trees main memory operations this is
where they meet way out there and and so
so what am i showing with this purple
line this purple line is a secondary
storage operation which features
compressed data so this is all
hypothetical right I don't have access
to the details our Facebook members but
the intent was for me to show was that
here when you're using compressed data
you you start way down here because
you're saving storage costs right
because you've just squeezed your
storage costs way down because you're
using only some fraction of the stories
you use in using before let's say it's
one third so so so this is going to be
one thirds of storage cost of the
uncompressed data sitting on secondary
storage and so
you're saving on storage costs he
remember this is where the data is not
being used at all okay but now when you
start using the data and you bring and
you start accessing it you bring it into
memory now you have to now you have to
start paying the cost of not only the IO
path and the AI ops you have to sit you
have to pay the cost of the CPU
compressing and decompressing the data
as well well if you compressed on main
memory using this curve that what that
look it would be to to lower the cost
here and raise the slope okay so when
you compress you lower you lower the
storage cost but increase the slope
because you're paying an execution cost
yeah systems you mean all the data have
to be yes there are techniques you're
not even even Microsoft healthy society
a technique for imperative right yes you
can support a code data on second your
storage for remember of my dear B's but
you don't marry the cost for that kind
of thing
so so to a first approximation nobody
uses all the systems that way oh I know
so Siberia was was was a research
project it's not part of the Microsoft
product what they've done you know this
is a complex space and I've obviously
simplified Apple but what they've done
is they've they've embedded Hecate on
code into the larger sequel server so if
you have Hecate on tables you can
execute Hecate on code on it but the
data has to be in main memory if you
have tables which are resident on
secondary storage then you have to use
the traditional sort of classic sequel
server engine on that you can do joins
across them but you you're committed to
to one or the other depending upon how
you define your tables so but but I
don't know of anybody who actually uses
Stonebraker had a paper on energy
caching also these all these all these
all these all these
efforts starting with main memory
database technology aren't really
designed to have most of the data seen
on secondary storage and so and so those
papers are all written in the following
style if the map if the data is too big
to fit and main memory will that's some
of it drift off to secondary storage but
that's not what I'm saying here what I'm
saying here is you want to push main
memory I want to put push data out of
main memory when it's not cost-effective
to leave it there and that could happen
long before you run out of main memory
it's because you're gonna free up main
memory for something somebody has a
higher use for it ok so it's the fact
that he said most data is called a
function of the volume of the data or of
just our message issues because I mean
it's something like LinkedIn it's like a
mostly story of temporary storage or us
ok yeah they're also yeah there's too
much data that the store in the main
memory Facebook even Mohan can't keep
facebook data hi you know I mean I I
don't know the island of the details of
how Facebook works where consists of two
interesting things about Facebook one
event when you put something on there
you never delete it so it gets very old
and very cold and second everything you
put on there is like tweet of 300
megabytes in size right everything put
on Facebook is quite large so they've
got either way they've got to push it
out of main memory
they only want to hear the main memory
when they need when they need it to
actually execute on the data this is a
paper that describes this secondary
storage architecture cold data oh yeah
one wall and it is really cold exactly I
think they use our angle meeting I think
they use an arc coggle yeah so when the
very very cost-conscious sure so so what
mall hands data will never be on
archival storage most of us he is the
person the friend of ours who posts most
frequently so some will work today
okay so so so this looks like a very
small area from which you're gathering
you know return on actually using
compression so but it isn't I just used
80/20 but the ratios between hot and
cold data could be enormous right so
most of the data is in fact sitting out
here in most applications and and you're
bringing data into main memory when it's
hot all right so okay so how do you make
a high performance and low cost data
caching system where am I so this is
this is this is gonna be very short so
so it's gonna go by quickly and it's not
animated in any way so so you're gonna
have to read it with me all right so
what is it what does it take to optimize
the cost of a data caching system well
so one thing is obvious one one way to
reduce the cost is simply increased main
memory its main memory performance right
as I indicated before if you have high
if you have a high performance the
higher your performance in main memory
the higher your performance of the main
memory portion of that curve will be
right so so that's one thing you can do
but you need scalability as well so so
it's not just performance you need to be
able to scale the performance as well
and that's tricky and and and the and
the the main memory database folks I
guess including us a bit to have tripped
all over themselves trying to get
scaling scalable performance out of
these multi-core systems and it's hard
we have thread-safe conflict-free code
that we execute all over the place where
one thread can execute any code other
people try partitioning where where you
get better performance but have a harder
time scaling because things cross
partition boundaries and once you cross
petition boundary is your performance
tanks so so so it's hard to get so it's
but this is one of the things you can do
if you want to if you want to improve
cost performance you improve performance
in main memory that's one of the thing
second is you can reduce the number of
i/os well you say well okay what does
what does that mean right me aren't we
always trying to just do the iOS that
are only that are required well so when
is an i/o required so one of the things
that's a property of both both what what
what we do in in in in in Deuteronomy
system and what rocks DB does is they
support we support blind writes what
does a blind write a blind write is I'm
gonna write it I'm gonna update
sometimes Coulter what is it i and up
sir
it doesn't matter what the state of the
object was before whether it even was an
object we're gonna create something and
put it in its the new state of the
object regardless of what the old state
was and so you don't have to look at the
old state to perform this operation if
you don't require that the operation
change data in place someplace so so in
in rocks DB world they have a local
in-memory table which they'll update for
us we do an update by posting a Delta
update to our mapping table in memory so
so a blind writes don't require a an
access to get the data to put the stuff
in the right place another another thing
here is what do I want to talk about
here
Oh blog structuring so so and this is
true again in a way with both rocks DB
and with our stuff which is which is you
take the pressure off the right side of
it at anyway by by only supporting large
writes and so you have a small number of
very large writes that you do that's the
characteristic of what log structuring
does you have these enormous buffers and
you and you write them out and instead
of having to write out every single page
individually where you have to execute
the i/o code path in the processor and
you don't have to buy an extra I up on
the on the on the SSD that reduces your
costs and improves your performance as
well
the right path a third thing is having
having a record cache so all these
numbers that I've shown you are mostly
shift will show flag you want what what
what the relative costs are or what the
relative access rates are for using a 4k
page but the smaller the memory unit
that your glog looking at the longer you
can afford to keep that unit in main
memory so if you have a record cache and
you can be more selective as well so if
you love a record cache you can keep
that record in main memory longer than
you can a paginating store which
contains a lot of extra data so that's
another thing and frankly both rocks DB
and us we do the Deuteronomy stuff do
that in a certain different ways but we
we both do it right and and we do it in
in my keeping our Delta updates around
and we also do it by having a record
cash and our transactional component as
well so so having having records as
opposed to as opposed to pages helps we
also have pages so we have a page cache
as well as those rocks needy but but the
fact that you have a record cache means
that you can keep the keep the data
around longer in main memory and get a
better performance out of it as well you
can reduce data movement cost between
secondary storage and memory and a bunch
of ways to do that one way is to make
the il path shorter by using user level
i/o that cuts out the operating system
what's you in charge of the cache of the
other schedule you buy one of the newer
SSDs which support larger number of AI
ops then that'll drive the cost down for
the AI ops as well or you can do what
we're trying to do this summer which is
to change what the SSD does this they
change what the SSD controller does sort
of the sort of interface that you when
you passed up back and forth between the
interface how you lower the cost and I'm
not going to talk about that in detail
because
because Yvonne is going to talk about
that next week but but it involves
getting in my world down and dirty with
the SSD and and thankfully Yvonne has a
little bit more experience with that
dirty part of the system than I do so we
count on him for doing the right stuff
and then you finally you can reduce the
cost of secondary storage now I've
talked about compressing compressing
data that's obviously one way to do it
that raises your operation cost but
that's certainly reduces your storage
cost and here's a sort of a gratuitous
comment which is that I don't think that
NVRAM is going to carry the day because
because it's a cost they don't tell you
what the cost is but that's a sure sign
it'll cost more than they'd like you to
know and so it's a factor of three or so
I'm guessing more expensive than flash
memory and and so used as a an SSD
technology it doesn't look so attractive
to me you can also say well what about
what about reducing secondary storage
costs by using disks and you can do that
too and you can use using tape as well
right so if you've got cold enough data
you've got cold enough data and you
don't have stringent access times
requirements to get to it then that's
what you should be doing right because
because when the when the access rate is
low enough the overwhelming part of the
cost that you're facing is the storage
cost which can be enormous so you want
to drive that storage costs down
appropriate with the level of heat that
you find in your data right so so that's
how you make it good cost performance so
a couple of caveats
our numbers are approximate right so all
of this and I'll show you how they are
approximate so performance is baseline
set of point experiments executed on our
machines using mostly our Deuteronomy
system so so so you know you generalize
it at some risk but you know I think
they tell a story that's interesting the
costs are taken from the web I scoured
the web looking for cost they vary a lot
even in one instant in time and they're
changing over time right so so it's not
a it's not a it's not something which is
etched in stone here like like that
don't your your next comment on on the
Amazon gravestone you know it's not
etched in stone but I think that the
general thrust of the results gives you
a good way of thinking about how to
design your system and why data caching
systems are in fact a very good idea so
that's one caveat second caveat is best
cost performance is not the only thing
that you need to worry about okay and
maybe it's not even the prime it may not
even be the primary thing that you worry
about so certainly it's always the case
that low cost is a plus but what you
want to maximize is not it's not the
minimizing cost you want to maximize
value which is the difference between
what you earn from processing the data
and what it costs you right and so if
you're one of these applications which
has really high value for that needs and
tremendous needs for low latency maybe
you don't want to use a data caching
system
maybe that's the niche where the main
memory stuff makes sense right because
you know they've got very high costs but
you know if the value is enormous and if
the value of sort of comes from your
being just a little bit faster than the
other guy
then then you you may be willing to
spend a whole lot more money and not
worry so much about the lowest cost and
so yeah so stock some of these thought
trading things are of that flavor but
there's not a whole lot I mean I think
the vast majority of the applications
are more concerned with with with you
know some sort of thing which is
suitable for an interactive system of
some sort now you know there's an
enormous spectrum and I'm not trying to
say that there's anything in between
because there is then you have to decide
which which which which place your
system fits in that but generally
speaking trying to minimize your cost
maximize your cost performance
a goal that most people and certainly
the the the traditional systems should
be aiming at as a way as a way to keep
the majority of their customers
happening all right
so recap and this is the critical thing
let's just want to remind you there's
two costs storage costs and execution
cost and you always pay the storage
costs even if nothing is happening on
your data right and so that's a really
significant aspect of that and so if
nothing's happening on your data you
want to work as hard as you can to
reduce the storage costs so when data is
cold storage cost is most of the cost
when data is hot then you say say well
okay execution cost really starts to
matter here but but most data most of
the time is cold and they win by moving
data between the low cost medium which
which doesn't have as much performance
but has a higher cost of operation they
move it from there to the high cost
medium main memory which is higher cost
on a sort of a time basis for the
storage but it has a lower execution
cost and and you switch between the two
based on what you approximate to be in
the crossover point and so still more or
less this we should be focusing on data
caching systems and their improvements
so this I can't leave you without
getting in a plug from our advertisers
this this talk is brought to you by the
BW tree in production it's in sequel
server it's the main rent only the main
memory part it's an adrià document DB
it's the one that makes it possible for
it's now called cosmos TD it makes it
possible for them to offer immediate
indexing of documents which are just
allotted and this is a real problem
because in what happens when a document
comes in it has index terms from all
over the key space and if you try to
update the whole key space immediately
you end up touching all the data and
having to bring it all in and this is an
example where the blind writes and being
able to execute code which does blind
writes but don't require putting this
stuff all of my home in the original
secondary storage location matters a lot
and then Bing object stores another
another place where we're used and there
are some references and so thank you for
your time the top reference is the de
menthe stuff it's actually I found out
something interesting when I submitted
my paper to Dame on I think this is ACM
maybe it's a cm general policy but they
offer you the option of retaining
copyright to your article and just
giving them use a certain kind of very
use and what day what you lose on that
is they won't defend your copyright like
they would if you would turn the
copyright over to them but it seems to
in my test my brief tested it it seems
to permit you to go to the ACM website
and and download the document without
without having to cross their pay wall
so but that I thought was sort of
interesting and maybe they only offer it
on workshops and not and not in their
conferences but but any rate I chose to
make it more widely available so you can
freely download it
I'm on this yep
look at that hard drives
hard disk drives where does that there's
that fitting on the post slot that's
been done on producing low-cost hard
drive systems with the expectation that
they're going to be used for very cold
data it's just another layer in the
hierarchy yes so I think that that's
that's exactly the right way to look at
it and and you know I think this is true
of Socrates that a lot of the data a lot
of data on hard disk and but when
they're actively running with data they
actually store a lot of it on SSDs so so
they staged it and and I think that
multi-level hierarchies are an
interesting way and it's a more
complicated system right every time you
introduce an extra layer in the system
the system becomes that much more
complicated but does money at stake so
so so going back for instance to nvram
technology I'm not a big I don't think
that nvram is going to play a big role
in the SSD market but I haven't ruled
out the fact that it might play an
interesting role that's simply a memory
extension where it's actually cheaper
than main memory than DRAM and and of
course it has the durability property
but it's slower as well so it too has I
can imagine you coming up with a with a
you know similar kind of curves to what
I've shown here which talk about when
you should migrate data between between
between your your cold main memory store
and your hot main memory store and I
think the same sort of reasoning applies
to that case except that the-- the cost
of moving the data between the two is a
lot lower so so I think that makes a
perhaps a reasonably attractive package
to go for but in terms of an SSD
replacement I don't think that I mean
until it's trying to sell it for that
but I'll fix your numbers you know
you're only showing less than a 6x
difference between SSD and DRAM and
you're trying to put something in
between you don't have a lot you don't
have a lot of flexibility there to deal
with I mean you
I don't attend there has to be data that
it has the right the right access rate
in what and and size longer to benefit
from having something so let me in that
in that narrow slot right I don't think
it's narrow as you think yeah so so what
the lower cost would be I think that the
cost difference between between DRAM and
main memory in between between well
bother me
we have way about pathway which it's
about a factor of three I think you need
directions ok so so so what you've seen
is as a curve which starts here right
which starts substantially below this
right and it has a curve on what its
cost increases are and its cost
increases in terms of terms of execution
just rather slow because rather well
smoke because the cost of executing that
doesn't include an idle path doesn't
include buying an i/o op and so it sort
of increases more gradually so think I
think I think that you might see that
this goes out over to here someplace
right in terms of in terms of the times
at which it's a lower cost operation now
all this is hypothetical because
nobody's built the system quite like
that yet but but I think that's an
interesting interesting thing to pursue
we're simply pursuing it in terms of
replacing replacing flash storage with
it all you do is add a factor of three
or so to the to the memory cost and you
don't change this line at all because
you still have the aisle access time and
blah blah blah so so so you've got it
you've got to think about it in terms of
in terms of how the entry comes in in
terms of what both its storage costs are
and its execution cost yes
so you're basically saying for that that
the green line will be shallower yes
that's right yes yes yes yes if you use
it as a main memory extension these cool
processors like GPUs the PTAs seems like
the cost per operation and I'm wondering
which way does that shadow so so I'm
quite know how to model them but I think
the important thing with those sort of
things is how much prep time you need
versus how much gain you get right and
and if you can if you can reduce the
prep time the same way if you can reduce
the if you can reduce the amount of code
you have to execute to do an i/o
operation that means you can afford more
i/o operations you can reduce the amount
of prep time that you need the amount of
computation you need for prepping those
those devices then you can use them more
frequently so uh so but I'll put I don't
have any great insight deep impression
on you right yeah compression is the
obvious place when I write better
what about power cost have you done you
look at that at all - no and people's
talked so much about the importance of
power efficiency and the data center is
that a factor here you know I mean it
was hard drives it was more obvious
because you're spinning this physical
thing this well semiconductor yeah so so
even even with hard drives what you got
things spinning it was the movement of
the alarm which is most of the most
power cost with with SSDs the power of
the power is only the based on the
access rates it's really stable medium
with us
so but I don't know a minute it's a lot
of clothes what about what about the
cost of building the facility what about
the cost of you know the getting the
customers to use it well you know
there's a lot of cost I think the
interesting thing here though is you've
got something which has a sort of a
component which has a multiplicity of
uses and and and its cost if you can
isolate its costs of you can in fact
compare costs between one thing and the
other you know if the application has
this a little enormous path through it
before you get to the data cashing store
in one form or another it has this a
long path then most of the cost is going
to be consumed in the application and so
maybe the maybe the data management
costs don't matter all that much anyway
but but I don't think you can think that
I don't I think that's a you if you go
down that path too far the end up saying
cost doesn't matter any place and and so
so you need to start taking costs
seriously everywhere right and and one
of the things the hackathon people found
was you know they did this they did this
storage engine which was enormous ly
faster than anything that they had
before and then they found well you know
yeah but the performance impact of that
on the whole database engine is hell
15 percent right or 20 percent right you
need to be able to attack the entire
path in order to be able to have a
significant impact on overall
performance and that's true of cost as
well so but but I don't do the rest of
the stack so I can only talk about data
management so thank you all for
listening
[Applause]
[Music]